i realized before i froze my eggs there
was just this constant inner monologue
that was like is this the guy you're
going to be with if not you have to move
on to someone else and i felt like i had
to accomplish all my professional goals
by the time i was like 35 and it was
just in the back of my mind all the time
like i'd be in traffic and i'd be like
you guys let's go i'm rotting from the
inside we gotta move okay
uterus is molding let's move
i feel like you guys will never
understand that pressure because you
guys don't have that clock guys can have
kids as late as they want clint eastwood
had a kid at like 70 years old robert de
niro had one of like 68 which is so
weird to me the idea of having a kid at
68 years old that's like being like i
really want a kid but only for like 10
years
and i want to be deaf for most of it
that's
i'm so glad i did it it took all this
pressure off like i used to be the
stress case now i'm just chilling man
so easy like my agent calls me up he's
like where's that script i'm like i
don't know i'm high as fuck
call sarah silverman or some shit man
because i'm watching game of thrones
again today
hey camera
i thank you
you freeze your eggs for a couple of
reasons if you want to postpone having
kids also if you want to get a surrogate
at some point which i'm kind of obsessed
with the idea of getting a surrogate
it's like you hire a woman to carry your
kid for you which i really want to do at
some point but i feel kind of guilty
about that idea because when you get a
surrogate you're essentially like asking
another woman to do your dirty work for
you it's like worse than a guy getting a
hooker because when you get a hooker you
guys just want to use a woman's body for
an hour i want to use it for nine months
and totally wreck it i'm literally gonna
destroy that shit
that's not nice
i just feel like i would like my kid so
much more if i didn't carry my kid
does that make sense
like i totally support those toddler and
tiara moms i think those kids should
work i think they should have to tap
dance to pay for all the damage they did
to those poor women
although i feel like if you have a
surrogate have your kid you can't
control the kid as well you know like
the way my mom used to guilt me into
doing things she'd be like i carried you
for nine months
i'd be like ah
that's a good
point but if like i had a surrogate what
am i gonna say i'm gonna be like i had
to drive 10 minutes
to pick you up traffic was a nightmare
yeah it's not as good
when you freeze your eggs the doctor
asks you if you want to get a donor like
a sperm donor because if you want to
freeze embryos you know like basically
if you freeze an embryo that means a
sperm fertilizes the egg and i was like
i don't have any sperm available in my
house at the moment um
so he's like maybe you should get a
donor and i wasn't really ready for that
but i got super obsessed with the kind
of person who would become a sperm donor
so i went online and i was like on the
donor site you'd think that sperm donors
were complete losers not true in order
to be a sperm donor you have to be at
least five eight
i was like i'm sorry what shallow bitch
was 45 years old not married no options
goes into the spur bank he's like oh
five seven never mind i'm gonna get on
farmers only and take my chances
fuck that weirdo midget
[Applause]
and in order to be a swarm owner you
have to have at least four years of
college i was like i don't want my sperm
donor to have four years of college
because if you have four years of
college and you're jerking off into a
cup for a hundred dollars
you're a drug addict
and if you don't have four years of
college and you're jerking off into a
cup for a hundred dollars you're an
entrepreneur and i like your hustle